and then finally we're going to either
mu is going to it's not a lot of nice
work using analytical tools and
developing analytics tools in learning
because this if we look at the spectrum
of expertise in this form so that people
in this room who know everything all of
you to ask questions because if you have
a question it's very likely that some
other people have questions even more
likely that there is somebody who is
what you discrete also is a similar
question so first question this is a
week longer thought so we want to know
but it is there but I also want to
encourage the speakers to stay with
sometimes because people would need a
break and okay now I'm going to talk
about analytic methods in supervised
learning
thanks to alcaman and the super the
organizers for inviting me the the I
just wanted to say that the as well
cannot mention I'm going to be speaking
about a variety of results
I mean machine learning and learning
theory in general it's just an enormous
field now and I'm going to be speaking
in particular only on mainly on topics
related to supervised learning which
I'll describe in a second and also
results that I think dovetail nicely
with some of the analytic tools that
show stuff we'll be talking about some
of the results that we've seen in
previous weeks here or you will see in
upcoming weeks and it's geared towards
those of you who have a strong math
background but not at all familiar with
results from learning theory so if you
are an expert in the area certain days
may be less exciting to you than others
let me just mention briefly what I mean
by supervised learning so in a
supervised learning scenario you're a
learner is given some data so one
example that I'll one common example is
from computational biology for example
as protein classification so this is
probably the only example that I'll give
throughout the mini course in protein
classification you're given a sequence
many sequences of amino acids
some amino acid sequence and you know
you can imagine that some biologist runs
an experiment in a lab and wants to know
whether it belongs to protein family a
or not some particular protein family so
you get an amino acid sequence and after
some expensive experiment that you've
run you label it plus if it belongs to
the protein family and look at some
other amino acid sequence around some
other complicated experiment you figure
out that it doesn't belong to some
protein family and so you end up with
this large labeled data set and of
course running these experiments is
expensive so what you'd really like to
do is undercover some sort of structure
in this data and come up with some
representation of the data H which is
frequently referred to as a hypothesis
so that when you receive you know
hopefully when you get a new amino acid
sequence and you'd like to classify it
instead of having to run some expensive
biological experiment you can plug in
the amino acid sequence into this
hypothesis H and it will fairly
accurately tell you yes it belongs to
protein family a or no it doesn't belong
to protein family a and the notion of
supervised here corresponds to the fact
that the data that you're given comes
associated with a particular label and
typically this label will be plus one or
minus one true or false would be binary
on the other hand what's nice about this
primitive of classification so
supervised learning is often referred to
as classification is that if you'd like
to do some other learning tasks say that
has more than one label it typically
reduces in some interesting way to two
classification so it's a very powerful
primitive for example if you'd like to
do optical character recognition you can
buy very expensive software packages
to do OCR and you have some text and
you'd like to know you know as each
character you know you just like to
recognize the characters of the text
automatically and and you want to
determine you know you know you could
run a classification task to determine
if each character in your text is a five
or not a five that would be one way to
do to do multi-class classification
using binary classification there are
other more sophisticated ways there's a
whole literature on it so one example of
a problem that is not a supervised
learning problem would be so something I
will not be talking about clustering or
learning mixture models you can imagine
you're given some points in RN and you
would like to find centers of the points
on the cluster them in some particular
nice way that's another way of
undercutting under you know finding
structure and data and I just won't be
covering it during the mini course it's
it's a very it's a huge interesting
field I don't mean to disparage it in
any way we just won't be looking at it
so let me just say that okay so let me
start off with another example that will
lead us into a variety of things that I
want to talk about
so one method you might use to come up
with some succinct representation of say
this database with amino acid sequences
labeled according to whether or not
belongs to some protein family would be
to use a decision tree so if you're not
familiar with the decision tree I'll
just define it using a picture you know
some it's a tree there's some root node
you're attempting to classify this
particular data so maybe at the root it
says look at index X look at the 5th
index if it's an a move this node in the
tree
it's a G this node in the tree or we
could say if it's an A or a T it's a G
or C this way and then this node might
say okay now look at the index 10 in
this amino acid sequence and so on and
so forth until you get to the root that
could be labeled plus 1 or minus 1
and so on and so forth and we'll say the
depth
length
longest path
and the size
isn't it vertices so one thing that oh
yeah you want me to write them you want
me to write bigger thank you okay well
will do thank you
right so one thing that's commonly done
in data mining is you would take this
this set of labeled examples and you
would run some algorithm which I'll talk
about in a second and you would hope
that you would find some relatively
succinct decision tree that does a good
job of classifying say you know in the
best-case scenario all of them but at
least most of them correctly and of
course what's trivial would be to come
up with a decision tree that is the size
of the label of the set of labeled
examples that you're given okay that's
totally trivial and it makes sense that
it's it's totally uninteresting it has
no expressive power you're you're taking
a you know you could call this just some
table of all of these labeled examples
and you're returning it back as your
hypothesis you haven't done any learning
you've merely copied over the labeled
examples that you've received so trivial
would be you know a decision tree of the
same size as the data
but now it's interesting is we can
consider the complexity of the following
problem problem 1 given a set of labeled
examples the promise that there exists a
decision tree size s consistent data so
I'll tell you that there is some
decision tree of size s that's
consistent with the data what is the
complexity
finding is such a decision tree I'll say
a consistent decision tree okay so you
know as I mentioned in you know machine
learning practitioners frequently will
take a data set and run some particular
algorithm and come up with a decision
tree that hopefully classify as much of
the data well but when we kind of more
formally look at this problem you know
so I can define it this way given a set
of examples I'll tell you that there's a
decision tree that's consistent with
this set of examples what's the
complexity of finding such a decision
tree it's open in fact the best known
algorithm is originally due to Erin
flaked and house ler
also there's a simpler proof due to
Auburn plum runs in time order n to the
log
where
and it's the length of your attribute of
your data points here is the dimension
of your data and thought of as vectors
and s here is the size of your
consistent decision tree okay so it's
still open as to whether or not there is
a polynomial time algorithm that will
output say a you know the best decision
tree that's consistent with your data
and also what's interesting is that on
the hardness side or you know I'm not
aware of any well I should be careful
about this so there are some hard well
I'll get to it in future lectures the
hardness is a bit more complicated to
describe but there are some some
hardness results that of a restricted
nature but in kind of in general
hardness is still kind of unknown
sorry what's your question yeah biggest
one is the smallest but it's a pig okay
yeah this is this is the exponent their
log is the smaller circle oh yeah yeah
yeah I see now about the world of the
biggest VD
of course you have to look at all the
data oh right right right right right
um right
Yeah right it was a little sloppy here
okay there are a couple of ways I could
get around this I guess what I'm trying
to say is that so really what you want
to do is it's a really way what you want
to do is fix and an S and draw sample of
sample s of labeled examples
and I'll let the size of s me polynomial
and N and s so yeah there's some there's
some well the way I'm trying to get
around this is basically imagine that
you fixed and the length of your example
and asked the decision tree then you're
going to draw some you know sequence of
examples and then now I've kind of
eliminated the randomness it's just to
accompany it's just a out on algorithmic
problem you have this fixed sequence of
examples you know what's the complexity
of finding yeah exactly so I'm going to
get to all these I'm just trying to give
a motivating example and in particular
like you know you could set the
parameter a little s to be I mean I mean
in that regard you can kind of take s to
be any polynomial you want to be in
little s yeah
good so I'm going to talk about decision
trees so let me now that I sort of
mentioned but let me make one sort of
trivial observation and that is that if
P equals NP then this task is easy
because I can simply guess a decision
tree of size little s and check that
it's consistent with all of my labeled
examples so this is really an
interesting computational problem where
we don't know the best known you know
the algorithm is the best known
algorithms are far from being polynomial
we don't have any satisfying hardness
results and it's also a problem that's
used very frequently by practitioners so
the sort of hope is that or the
possibility that that's out there is
that there is some algorithm that we've
missed and that's sort of one of the
motivating reasons for continuing to
study these types of problems so let me
just kind of pause here and give an
outline for what I want to do for the
rest of the mini course so today I'm
going to talk more about decision trees
and I'm gonna go over some of the real
you know seminal or classic results in
computational learning theory from
probably twenty years ago so this this
will involve algorithm B an algorithm a
query algorithm for learning decision
trees its immense or and I'll mention
the low-degree algorithm unio men sort
Nissan which sort of introduced the
Fourier method into supervised learning
and hopefully I'll get to talk about
Quinta's and then source conjecture
so what I'd like to get through today
are sort of the classic results from
supervised learning from you know 25
years ago that that that are very
related to kind of Fourier learning and
some of the topics that just off will be
we'll be discussing then on day two I'm
going to talk about learning with noise
and also connections between hopefully
connections between the way stability
and other topics from the analysis of
boolean functions to learning then once
we've done kind of talked about all of
these algorithms some I'm gonna try and
focus on algorithmic aspects of of all
of these results whenever I can I'll
sort of state the necessary kind of
structural theorems but I won't have
time to really prove any of them so
after these kind of initial concepts on
learning and then learning with noise on
day three we'll talk more about learning
high-dimensional
convex sets so on day three I'll sort of
be using some of the results from day
one and day two to be able to talk about
some connections between high
dimensional geometry and learning that
will be very related to some of the
things that we've talked about in days 1
& 2 but some very interesting results
from analysis will come into play here
on day 3 and then on day 4 I would like
to get back to talking about hardness
results various reductions among
learning problems and also hopefully
kernel methods
on day two in the learning with noise
section we'll probably also have to make
a digression into losing hours so this
is my plan okay so getting back to
learning decision trees - it's a nice
open problem there's one if we give the
learner extra power to try and learn
these decision trees so if the learner
loud query access then we'll see that we
can we can actually do much better than
if we're just given it a randomly
sampled sequence of set of examples so
let me define what I mean by this let me
give you a more formal setup
so I'm going to fix C to be a class of
functions and in particular I'll let C
be the class of size s decision trees
and so I'll treat every C&C well for
right now on that zero one okay so
typically see here is a boolean function
and you know the script C is often
referred to as a concept class and I'm
going to assume that a learner just get
in black box access to the unknown
okay so so learner pick x01 to the end
of his choosing and receives f of X and
the goal output some hypothesis H
that's a probability from X and 0 1 to
the end that H of X is not equal C of X
is Epsilon okay so I've already made so
this is the I've already kind of changed
the model that we're working in when I
mentioned this particular problem
there was no this was sort of a
distribution independent setting you
were given a labeled sequence of
examples you had no idea what
distribution they came from and you're
asked to find a decision tree that was
consistent with this set of labeled
examples now I'm making the task and
this is a difficult task so now I'm
making the task much easier I'm putting
an underlying distribution on the space
that we're working at with so I'm
assuming that we're trying to learn with
respect to the uniform distribution on 0
1 to the end here and I'm doing that by
saying that your hypothesis that you
that you output has to be correct but it
has to be correct only with respect to
the uniform distribution on examples
furthermore I'm letting you pick the
examples that you would like to see and
their labels so in the kind of classical
decision tree learning problem you're
simply given a batch of labeled examples
and you're asked to find some decision
tree that fits the sequence of examples
and this is sort of the uniform
distribution
learning problem
now of course we'd love to learn
decision trees with respect to arbitrary
distributions I would love to say you
know you're given examples from some
decision tree chosen according to some
arbitrary distribution and you're able
to output some hypothesis that agrees
with the unknown decision tree with
respect to this arbitrary distribution
that would be great
but you know we have to start somewhere
and it's a considerably easier problem
to make an assumption on the
distribution so we'll see you know
throughout the mini course that we'll
have to make a variety of you know
hopefully weaker and weaker assumptions
on the distributions that we'd like to
learn with respect to so the kind of one
of the most common restrictions to make
is the uniform distribution on 0 1 to
the N and also another thing to note
here is that I'm allowing the learner to
output a hypothesis H and I've said
nothing about the structure of H so H
need not be a decision tree H just needs
to be some polynomial time computable
hypothesis so it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be a decision tree and
we'll see that the algorithm I'm about
to describe that if not questions about
the learning model or anything yeah
don't yet to put some restrictions I
mean otherwise the hypothesis could just
be I mean you pick polynomial in many
samples right yes I mean the path of
this could just be output 0 if you
haven't seen it otherwise output what we
have seen right but so I mean that
hypothesis when you receive a new
example that you haven't seen before
what's it going to do it's going to say
0 right that's going to be a bad
hypothesis ok so you take this is
something actually it's kind of legal to
do but it would be stupid it wouldn't
right you you want the hypothesis the
output to have some sort of
generalization power otherwise it can be
anything so
and so it didn't clarify the 20 fighters
I think if Department quantifiers are
yeah so it should be that so there
should so there should what you want is
an algorithm a so fixed algorithm a such
that for all C and C when given access
to this concept class it outputs a
hypothesis H that is epsilon accurate so
you don't know what C is right you don't
know what silly you want H to be epsilon
far from all C's which are consistent on
the samples from the queries that you
made from the class script C you you
want hypothesis that's epsilon close to
I mean I mean you don't have to
necessarily output C but you need to
output something that there might be
more than one seem absolutely on all
those queries that you absolutely so you
can output anyone no I mean you want to
be epsilon far from all of them close
have son close yeah close to all right
right
so I mean I mean let me just just say it
kind of as an aside you know there's
this notion
there's this old notion in learning
theory called basically Occam's razor or
compression implies learning which
basically says that so well this is
really sort of an aside but if you want
to learn a concept class see
it suffice is did you take let's assume
that the size of C is finite it suffice
us to take roughly log size of the
consequent concept class the function
class over Epsilon random examples and
output some C that is consistent
with examples so this is sort of a
sufficient condition for doing for doing
distribution independent learning you
have some fixed concept class see you
can choose roughly order log size of the
concept class over Epsilon examples and
if you're able to find another function
in the concept class C that is
consistent with the sequence of labeled
examples then you'll have this guarantee
that the concept the consistent concept
class the consistent function that
you've output actually has is epsilon
accurate with respect to the entire
distribution so this is this is a
sufficient condition for learning with
respect to any distribution you can take
some batch of examples you can find a
function that's consistent with dispatch
of examples and with high probability
this function that you've output will be
epsilon accurate with respect to the
entire distribution so we'll have the
kind of generalization power that you
were asking about now here and for the
rest of the week we'll be talking about
a case where the distribution is not
arbitrary at some specific distribution
and so we won't have to rely on using
this type of condition to show that your
hypothesis has some good generalization
power we'll be able to say you know use
the fact that we're working with
specific distributions
so let me show you the algorithm
you
since that for example here all the dogs
will have x1 - yes you're saying it's
it's more than just an arbitrary sparse
policy so you're saying I don't know how
to go from the polynomial back to the
decision tree yes absolutely
so that's why I was emphasizing the fact
that the learner doesn't have to
actually output a decision tree
according to this criteria it just has
to output some some polynomial time
computable hypothesis and what it will
output will be a a sparse polynomial
okay so it's going to be convenient it's
gonna be convenient to shift from
the zero one to the end domain the plus
one minus one to the end domain so I'm
going to view all of these decision
trees as mapping plus 1 minus 1 to the
end plus 1 minus 1
so it's a change of basis
and in which case after this change of
basis this polynomial will become the it
will then be the Fourier polynomial for
this decision tree so let me just just
talk about this kind of for one second
yeah well so let me get to that in a
second yes this parcel the sparsity will
change but the l1 norm will not change I
mean if you're I mean strictly speaking
you know if you define sparsity to be
the number of nonzero terms then it's
not going to be sparse in the Fourier
basis and it'll be closely approximated
by something that is sparse in the
Fourier basis let me get to it in just a
second so so since we're trying to learn
my perspective on you know learning with
respect to particular distributions is
one from sort of an approximation sort
of an approximation Theory perspective
okay so we have some function from +1 -1
to the ends of the reals and the
distribution the underlying distribution
is uniform plus 1 minus 1 to the end now
anytime you have a set of functions that
are bounded in some way and here they're
boolean so they're all bounded and you
have a distribution on some product
space you can look at an orthogonal
family of polynomials these are
polynomials like these are a family of
polynomials in the univariate case it
would just be well let me just say these
are so there's some index set say I have
some polynomial P s indexed by a since
I'm calling Meal T in this particular so
basically what's going to happen here is
you're going to come up with some family
of polynomials and some inner product
where for every two polynomials that are
different their inner product is going
to be 0 for every two polynomials that
are the same in this family their inner
product will be 1 and these polynomials
are going to be dense in l2 with respect
to the functions that you're looking at
ok so I guess for this particular I mean
show stuff we'll probably talk much more
about this but for this particular case
the orthogonal family of polynomials
that we're interested in will be parity
functions
on the variables x1 through xn and 4s
some subset of n define pi of s of X to
be the product variables
yes
so if
I have 1/2 of X it's just going to be
the monomial x1 times x2 so my
orthogonal family of polynomials here
are going to be all 2 to the N monomials
of length N and the inner product so if
I have two polynomials is and chi-chi T
will have that the expectation is and
sky T this is going to be the inner
product for X is from minus 1 1 to the N
0 if s does not equal T and 1
you know the reason why I'm mentioning
orthogonal families of polynomials here
is that in later lectures instead of
learning functions that map from plus 1
minus 1 to the end to R and the uniform
distribution we'll look at functions f
that map's a RN to R and the
distribution might be Gaussian for
example so instead of being uniform on
the cube the distribution might be
Gaussian and then we'll have a different
family of orthogonal polynomials they
will still have the nice property that
you know with respect to a particular
inner product any two different mu2
north it'll be an orthonormal basis for
the for the family of functions that
we're interested in so for any two
functions that are different their inner
product will be 0 and for any two basis
functions that are the same the inner
product will be 1 and as I mentioned
these polynomials are dense this
orthogonal family of polynomials is
dense so what does that mean well in
this case it means that for any
for any app mapping +1 -1 Z is f can
actually be written as some linear
combination these monomials so I'm using
this notation but I like to think of it
as just you know for any function
mapping the hypercube to the reals
because you have this nice orthogonal
family of polynomials that's dense with
respect to this function class you can
write f as some linear combination of
these monomials and in order to describe
this particular algorithm the only other
fact I'll need is parse appalls equality
which says that the expectation of the
square of the function is the square of
the Fourier coefficients
okay so to see if this made any sense
let me state the following fact that
should be easy so if F is boolean
and gee
not boolean but we have that expectation
of minus G squared is less than or equal
to Epsilon it implies that the
probability the sine of G is not equal f
of X
so what this basically says is that I
have this decision tree I'm going to
think of it as some unknown polynomial
and I've shifted from working from zero
one to the end two plus one minus one to
the end so I'm thinking of it as some
linear combination of parity functions
and remember you have black box access
to this unknown polynomial and if you
can find some function G such that the
expectation of F minus G squared is at
most Epsilon then your hypothesis that
you're looking for what you want output
is the sine of gene because the sine of
G will differ from F in at most Epsilon
so this is going to be the hypothesis
that you're interested in outputting
so this is an easy fact so let me recap
what this what the goal of this
algorithm is it's so you're given black
box access to f4 to see
and you would like to minimize overall
polynomials P sparsity the most T the
expectation of C minus P squared and
this is what you want to approximately
minimize
so we've taken the task which is
learning and under decision tree and
you're given black box access to this
decision tree we've reduced it to the
task of minimizing over all polynomials
that have some sparsity parameter T the
expectation of C minus P squared
okay so I guess at a high level you have
black box access to see it's some
unknown polynomial what is the what is
the polynomial that of sparsity at most
T that minimizes this quantity well the
answer is that it's the polynomial that
takes the T largest coefficients of P so
minimizer
this quantity
is the polynomial P
that takes the largest
coefficients
and this is easy to see because by a
Parsifal equation this expectation is
exactly the sum of the squares of the
coefficients of P that you did not take
so note that if you know if I had
written here instead of expectation of C
minus P squared if I had written
expectation of absolute value of C minus
P then it's suddenly like less clear
what polynomial should take but because
we have the two here because we're
working with respect to the two norm and
we have parseval's equation it's clear
that the polynomial that minimizes this
program is the one that just takes the
largest coefficients of your unknown
decision trees
okay do you mean that exactly
see yes did I say sorry sorry largest an
absolute value yes
and that's what this particular
algorithm is going to do and the way
that it's going to do it is the highly
the so the algorithm is actually you
know it's very beautiful it's very
simple so again you're going to build a
tree so if I'm going to have C and on
the left half of the tree I'm going to
come up with some function which I'll
call c1 let me just sum function which
we'll call c1 and this is going to
correspond to the sum of the squares so
I guess some of should I write this
such that s begins with zero so
literally the I'm going to fit you know
every monomial can be indexed according
to a string and I'm going to fix the
first bit of this string to be zero so
think of this is sort of a we're
building a prefix to this coefficient
and on this side of the tree I'm going
to have the sum of all the squares of
the Corey Fourier coefficients where s
begins with up one so the sum of the
squares of all the Fourier coefficients
the sum of the squares of all the
coefficients of C is equal to the sum of
the squares of all the coefficients on
this left branch plus the sum of the
squares of all the coefficients on this
right branch and then I'm going to kind
of so remember so the goal here is to
find large coefficients
so I know that the sum of the squares of
all the coefficients is one it's a
boolean function so here I'll get some
estimate on the sum of the squares of
all the Fourier coefficients that begin
with zero and here with one and then
here I'll get an estimate we'll we'll
estimate what the sum of the squares of
all the Fourier coefficients where the
coefficient kind of begins with zero
zero and where the coefficient begins
with zero 1 1 0 and 1 1 and we'll
recurse and at the bottom of this tree
we'll have a string of length n and this
will correspond to exactly one fourier
coefficient it'll correspond to the
coefficient that has this as its index
and so it's sort of a recursive
procedure the algorithm will look at the
sum of the squares of the Fourier
coefficients going this way and on this
branch if at any time it finds that the
sum of the squares of the Fourier
coefficients on one particular branch is
very small it will abandon its search on
that branch and it will continue its
search down some other particular branch
so
to this end let me define function c
alpha of X so I don't get this so this
is going to be the sum over all Z so
alpha is going to be a string of length
K and then we'll sum for Z in 0 1 to the
N minus K C hat of alpha Z
so this is a function and you can see
that it sort of corresponds to all of
the Fourier coefficients where that that
are that have alpha as a prefix of this
particular Fourier coefficient so for
temple alpha Z is of length n sub C yes
no I don't think so
the question is of those thickened a
lower dimensional cube world yeah
they're taking they're taking they're
taking Overlord a natural cube yeah I
mean X X here is in no I I don't I mean
I I guess I want to say I want to say so
well see if the empty set of X should
just be see this and then expectation of
C squared should equal expectation of C
of 1
and the main theorem that C alpha of X
is equal to the expectation of y y of X
I alpha y furthermore C alpha of X so
why why are we in good shape that this
theorem is true well it gives us a way
to actually with query accent remember
we have query access C and we'd like to
be able to sample the X so we want to be
able to sample we want to estimate
expectation of C alpha because this
exactly corresponds to the mat the sum
of the squares of the coefficients that
have alpha as a prefix so if we have
this theorem we're in really good shape
because I want to estimate the
expectation of C alpha of x squared so
what will I do well I'll I'll sample
random X's for each X that I choose I'll
sample random wise to estimate this
particular expectation and then you can
see if you want to estimate C alpha of X
to any additive epsilon it's simple I
can pick random X's for each X I can
pick random Y's I'll get an an X I'll
get within some additive Epsilon a very
good estimate of C alpha of X and so
that will give me a good estimate of the
expectation of C alpha of x squared and
that will be sort of the sampling
routine that I'll need to carry out this
or
kurzon yes this is all for the uniform
distribution right
can you say your question again I mean
I'm allowed to query on any point that I
want so yeah this is concatenation so
it's important to have query access
right it doesn't work if you get given
random example yes well as I said yeah
so it's it's it's a that's an unknown
hard problem right that I'll be talking
about this again so so just so we can
say we did one proof I'm gonna consider
this quantity
and I'm going to expand out see Y of X
and then I'm taking my expectation over
why so everything that doesn't involve Y
can be pulled out
and I'm left with the expectation of why
okay so here I have two monomials KY of
Z 1 and Chi of alpha and my expectation
is over oh yeah
so here I have an expectation over Y
here of two monomials so this is going
to be 0 if Z 1 1 otherwise so what I'm
left with when you make this
simplification where it's d1 has to
equal alpha it's just the sum over z2
this is and this is exactly what we
wanted this is the theorem this is
exactly the definition of my function
where the prefix is equal to alpha
so given this theorem as I said we know
how to sample now or estimate the sum of
the squares of all coefficients of the
polynomial that begin with some
particular prefix now the depth of this
recursion so if you consider this like a
recursive algorithm the depth of this
recursion is most n and the width of the
recursion so I guess I should have had
an input parameter theta and you want to
return coefficients they're greater than
equal to theta the width of this
recursion is at most one over theta
squared well there can be at most one
over theta squared coefficients that
have magnitude greater than or equal to
theta because the sum of the squares of
all the coefficients is at most one so
you have this recursion recursive
algorithm the depth is at most n the
width is at most one over theta squared
where theta is the input parameter of
the size of the coefficient you're
looking for and so this implies that the
algorithm is polynomial in N 1 over
theta and then of course epsilon here is
going to correspond to some air that
comes into play when you do all of this
sampling to try and estimate the sum of
the squares of the Fourier coefficients
so but still
you expand the branch so for any branch
that where the sum of the squares is
less than theta squared you just you end
terminate so at a very high level you're
kind of fixing prefixes you're kind of
restricting the label of the
coefficients of the polynomial until you
can kind of hone in on ones that have
large magnitude and as Johann said you
you absolutely need query access in
order to estimate the sum of the squares
of the Fourier coefficients on any kind
of branch of this tree good so so if you
want to minimize as I said if you want
to minimize the expectation weird over
all P where is sparse
this is but you want if you want to
approximately minimize this quantity so
you see you're going to output that
expectation of C minus P squared is less
than or equal to Epsilon so there's
going to be some error and this epsilon
will play into the error of that
particular epsilon but as I said once
you found this P that is essentially all
the large coefficients of the polynomial
that correspondent to that decision tree
then you can just output the sign okay
so I'm not done but so tomorrow I will
discuss what happens when instead of
minimizing expectation of C minus P you
want to estimate absolute value of C
minus P and there are good reasons for
doing this and the algorithmic problem
becomes much harder because it's no
longer as I said it's no longer clear
that the best thing that you should do
is to just take all of the large
coefficients of C we'll talk about that
tomorrow
okay great so what's still open
it's still open is well there many open
problems one is if the learner does not
have query access
see and instead receives uniform random
examples can you still learn the
underlying decision tree or can't you
find all of these large coefficients of
the underlying polynomial this is opened
and I definitely don't know of any good
hardness results for this particular
problem so there are two there are two
kind of related questions one is
when you say something is open you mean
you don't know how to do it in
polynomial thing where you don't know
how to good question
we definitely which I was going to talk
about in just a second we definitely
know how to learn decision trees in
quasi quasi polynomial time so just the
polynomial time algorithm is is what's I
know there are two related questions
that I wanted to talk about one is
learning formulas
so we'll see in a second this is an
easier problem harder problem so let me
talk about the harder problem for just a
second
recall that when you have a decision
tree
it's easy to see that any size s can be
computed by a DNF formula with s terms
for example if I have a decision tree
here this is X 3 X 7 X 4 and let's say
that this goes to plus 1 then I can
consider the term X 3 bar and X 7 and X
4 this is a term you can just take the
or of all of the terms that correspond
to paths that arrive at a plus 1 in a
decision tree since there at most it's a
size s there at most s leaves you'll get
a DNF formula with S terms
and a natural question is
given in a formula s terms does there
exist a polynomial such that well does
there exist a sparse polynomial P that
approximates this DNF formula so let me
write it this way does there exist a
polynomial P such that P is s to the
order log 1 over Epsilon sparse and
expectation of
F expectation of P minus F squared is
less than or equal to epsilon so it
shouldn't depend on n the question is
given a DNF formula you have s terms is
there a polynomial P with sparsity s to
the log 1 over epsilon that epsilon
approximates this particular function if
so so then by using the algorithm for
learning decision trees for finding
large Fourier coefficients then there is
an S to the order log 1 over epsilon
time algorithm
but learning DNF formulas and this is
this is men source conjecture
and actually it would be interesting
it's open and it would be interesting to
prove an S to the F of epsilon bound
where F is any function of Epsilon this
is still not known so so this conjecture
was made and the motivation was that
since we know how to learn decision
trees when the learner has given query
access to the decision tree if we could
prove just this structural result about
DNF formulas then we would immediately
get a learning algorithm for DNF
formulas now it just so happens to turn
out that that Jeff Jackson gave a poly
time algorithm probably time query
algorithm for poly saponin Emile size
that did not resolve man source
conjecture so you may be wondering well
sort of who cares about men source
conjecture we know that you can learn
DNF formulas given query access it's a
really great result but we'll see
tomorrow when I talk more about learning
with noise that this conjecture is still
implies some interesting things that we
don't know and so we know some very kind
of we know that man source conjecture is
true for some very restricted settings
for example if the DNF formula is
randomly chosen appropriately from some
class then we know that this conjecture
is true but otherwise you know nothing
is known the other question that I
wanted to talk about is learning
so okay hunter is function f it depends
only on K now one thing to notice so
okay so so the interesting open problem
and what's unknown
is so it's easy to see actually that if
your learner is given query access to
this unknown function then you can learn
it you can find you know the difficulty
in this particular problem is finding
what these kind of relevant K input bits
are and if the learner is given query
access it's easy to see that you can
sort of solve this problem the open
problem is just given random examples
from plus 1 minus 1 to the N so you're
not allowed quit the learners not
allowed query access but you're still
giving you uniformly random examples
from plus 1 minus 1 to the N you you
want to output it's the usual criterion
you want to output an H F is an unknown
K Hunta
you'd like to output an H such that the
probability thanks Epsilon
one way to solve this particular problem
is to use brute force search and to
enumerate all sets of K relevant
variable of K variables and basically
see you know once you've picked your set
of potentially relevant variables you
can see if you can in fact you could use
brute force search and search over all
possible functions on those K input bits
and see if you found the right set of K
relevant variables it's not difficult to
see that this works and it'll have a
running time of n to the order K times
some function of K this will correspond
to say doing brute-force search over all
possible functions on K variables but
it's it's this term that you're trying
to improve upon and what you'd really
like to do is have a running time of say
n to the little o of K or you know for
example 2 to the K times Pauline you
know this this would be very interesting
so one thing to note
so note that any order login linty i a
poly sighs okay so this is to say that
and certainly you know we definitely
don't know how to learn log and juntos
in polynomial time so this is to say
that the the decision tree problem
namely learning an unknown decision tree
when you don't have query access is
harder than the hunter problem I mean if
you it's it's a good motivation for
studying the hunted problem if you're
really interested in learning polynomial
size decision trees then you really need
to make progress on the problem of
learning que tantos first
okay and yeah so I was going to say that
I was going to sketch
so Elkin on Donnellan said sir video
gave an end to the mission say Oh an end
to the Omega over Omega plus 1 times K
time algorithm where Omega is the matrix
multiplication exponent and there's been
a recent work by Greg valiant that
improves this slightly it might be you
might be able to do end to the point six
8k it's actually a very cute result that
if I have time off get into it maybe
since I'm out of time basically what
I'll do is I also I'll finish up a
couple of loose ends from this lecture
including this result and then we'll
start talking about learning with noise
and discuss some more sophisticated
optimization problems corresponding to
minimizing with respect to L one norms
instead of Elinor's
so I'll stop here